Joining me today is a New Zealand born author,
speaker and founder and head mistress of Mckayla community school,
a free school established in London all the way back in 2014.
Catherine verbal saying welcome to the Rubin report.
Hi.
I'm very happy to have you here.
Hello.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
I've heard a rumor that you sometimes play my videos in your classrooms.
Well,
I don't know about the classrooms,
but among staff,
among staff in the school,
somewhere in the school,
in this school.
Definitely.
Um,
we're all fans.
Thank you.
Far too controversial to play in the classroom.
Yeah,
I think so.
Uh,
there's so much I want to talk to you about,
about education,
your,
your personal,
sort of political evolution,
all the things that you've been through.
So I always like finding out a little bit about somebody's history at the top
and you come from a long line of teachers and some interesting background stuff.
So tell me a little bit about young Catherine.
Well,
um,
how many my parents,
my father is Indian guy,
niece.
My mum is Drake and black.
Jamaican.
I say that because the whole race thing is important,
you know,
uh,
bizarrely,
cause these days,
you know,
people are so much more interested in who said it as opposed to what is being
said.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
somewhat some random person set up a Wikipedia page for me.
And there was this kind of major,
uh,
argument going on between my detractors and,
and the people who support me.
People that support me,
one of the truth to be there.
The people who didn't like me wanted it to,
wanted me to be Indian rather than black because black was kind of a bigger
victim.
And to discredit me,
they needed to push me up the,
the victim pole,
you know?
Yes.
So my hit hard following the oppression Olympics,
the whole operation of it.
Yeah,
I know.
Exactly.
And so,
uh,
you know,
my,
my uh,
mother was a nurse,
my father taught at university and,
and came from,
you know,
dirt poverty in Ghana,
but is one of those extraordinary people who made something of himself through
hard work.
And,
um,
I was born in New Zealand and then I grew up in Canada and then I've now been in
London for nearly 30 years.
And,
uh,
I went to Oxford University and I've been a teacher ever since.
And I was a very left wing teacher,
a very typical teacher in that way.
Yeah.
And I used to write a blog,
um,
which was called to miss with love based on the book and film Sir to Sir with
love,
you know,
Sidney Poitier was in the film and um,
I wrote this blog a few times a week.
I'd go home and write about how little Johnny had his money stolen and that kind
of thing.
Things that made me really upset about the education system.
And Ah,
wait,
let's pause for a second before you get to get to the point where you sort of
woke up and got into trouble and they don't have people fighting on your
Wikipedia page.
So what,
what sort of education did you have that pushed you towards leftism or was it
just,
just how it was Kinda like where did those ideas come from?
Did that,
did that come from schools that come from family?
Was it media?
I suppose my family.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
it's really interesting cause I think,
ethnic minorities really are small c conservative naturally.
Uh,
but because,
uh,
the black vote normally goes to the left.
Uh,
my family was no different from,
from a typical,
uh,
fam,
you know,
ethnic family in that sense.
And so I was brought up in a,
in a,
in a left wing household.
Why do you think they generally vote small,
cutesy,
conservative or that why they think that?
Why do they internally either think it or have been taught to think it?
I think they come from small c Conservative,
um,
uh,
backgrounds.
So when I say that,
just the belief in and pulling yourself up from your own booze but your own
bootstraps,
um,
hard work will get you somewhere.
Uh,
personal responsibility being stoical when things are difficult.
Um,
but the kind of thing that makes people successful.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I think minorities,
especially the ones who've been immigrants,
moved somewhere new.
They believe in giving their children a better life and in working hard in order
to be able to do so.
So it fits with them now.
So you come from a small seed conservative family,
but kind of voting left.
Yes.
Then that's right.
And then I'm a teacher,
so everyone I know is on the left and I don't speak to any conservative people
because that's how it is.
There's this big divide and nobody ever speaks to each other.
I didn't know any conservative people or the way conservative people thought.
And then I was writing this blog and that's where I started meeting conservative
people and I say meat on my blog.
So Twitter didn't exist in those days.
People would have discussions on the blog comment section and uh,
all these left wingers would come on and start attacking me and telling me how
awful I was with the stories that I was writing and how can I judge the
education system as I was judging it.
And,
uh,
all these conservatives would come on and defend me and I'd be saying to the
left wingers,
no,
I want to,
well,
I'm one of you,
you know,
I'm with you.
I'm a good person.
And they'd say,
no,
you're a right winger.
And I'd say,
well,
of course I'm not on the right.
Of course I'm not conservative.
I'm a good person.
So how could I possibly be conservative?
And the Conservatives would come on and say,
I think you'll find that you are.
And over years of me writing and me insisting that I was on the left,
I came to realize that I wasn't yeah,
that my instincts,
the things that I valued,
the values,
it's those basic values of personal responsibility and,
and,
and perseverance and,
and being happy with competition and all that kind of stuff.
Um,
I,
I liked,
and then I realized like I came to realize slowly and,
and then I met a few people.
So like I met you would be interested because you're always interested in
meeting people who don't think like you.
I met this guy.
So there was this guy used to come onto my blog called a British national party
member.
So he was,
he was just,
I mean,
people call it the fascist party,
you know,
and in the day they had a lot more power than they do nowadays.
And um,
so he was part of the BNP and I would let him come on my blog.
So all of these kinds of lefties were outraged.
How can you let them come on your blog?
You need to ban him.
But I always thought just comments.
So commentator,
he would comment and get into discussions sometimes with me and sometimes with
other people and some of the left wingers would refuse to talk to him at all,
you know,
and they get really angry with me and the team that I should just say,
you're not allowed to be on here.
And then,
you know,
he was on there for ages,
this is over years.
And then,
um,
and then I said,
you know,
it'd be really interesting to meet you because you're very different from
anybody I know.
And so I met this guy and you know,
I mean he was a racist,
you know,
I mean he was,
the things that he believed about black people and so on.
He wasn't racist.
But you know what I always say is some of my best friends are racist.
You know,
it's like avenue Q,
you know,
the,
the musical with,
you know,
everyone's a little bit racist and people are racist on different levels.
You know,
sometimes you're really racist,
sometimes you just a little bit racist.
Anyway,
I met with him,
he was wearing a suit.
He's young White Guy,
I'm wearing a suit and nice shoes.
And then he went and he took me for lunch.
He paid for lunch.
That's right.
That's what's so interesting about life.
Right.
And um,
so we went for lunch and he was hobbling along and I said,
you know,
you are right.
And he said,
Oh,
you know,
the thing is I bought this suit and,
and these shoes,
cause I was meeting with you and you know,
you went to Oxford University and I figured I've got to get dressed up,
you know.
But the sh the shoes are new and they're really hurting my feet.
And I feel isn't that interesting?
Here's this racist who was taking me for lunch,
who's wearing new shoes that he's bought.
Cause I've been to Oxford,
you know,
and that's what's so interesting about life is that it's not as easy as some of
the left put people.
You know,
you're a racist,
you're not a racist,
you're a good person,
you're a bad person.
You're this,
it's not like that.
There's a whole variety of different ways of seeing people and learning from
people.
And,
um,
was he able to learn from you after that?
Well,
we met a second time and you know,
I mean when I say he was,
I mean like he was telling me about how that morning he'd been to see his
girlfriend and they have a toddler and uh,
he'd gone to see her and see the baby.
She wouldn't let him hold the baby because she knew that he was coming to see me
and she said,
you're going to contaminate him cause you're going.
Exactly.
Um,
but,
you know,
he was a good guy in so many other ways.
And that's what,
that's what's interesting about life is what I'd say,
um,
is that,
uh,
nobody's perfect and people change their minds.
You know,
I think about my parents who lived in the same house for 46 years in Toronto.
And,
um,
there was a man called Mr. Snow who lived opposite them.
And when he moved,
when they moved into the area,
it was all white and he was outraged because he was a racist and he thought,
no way,
I don't want these people living there.
And over the years,
over the 46 years,
they got to know each other and they became friends.
And in the end,
Mr Snow's wife,
you know,
she,
she got cancer and she died.
And Mr. Snow,
uh,
I had to depend on my parents for a whole lot of help and,
and my parents loved Mr. Snow and Mr. Snow loved them.
Um,
you know,
things can change,
people can change.
And when Mr. Snow died,
my parents moved house because the,
the,
the community they lived in and had,
had died.
We've,
we've,
Mr. Snow and this was the man who was so racist.
He didn't want them to live there.
You know,
isn't it personally powerful too?
I mean,
I can feel it when you're saying it,
that when you can accept some people for all their flaws,
that it actually allows you to figure out how to grow instead of just othering
them forever.
Even,
even if they might do that to a whole set of people for awful reasons.
Yeah.
Well,
and they can change.
I mean,
people change their minds.
You know,
I have this quote in my office from Muhammad Ali that says,
um,
you know,
for man at 40 still thinks the same way as when he was 20,
then he's lost 20 years of his life,
you know?
Um,
and,
and thank God we can change.
I mean,
when I think about how I used to think,
you know,
and how I think now,
um,
well that's what life's all about,
right?
So,
okay,
so let's back up to some of those ideas,
because,
so you were,
you were a lefty and then you started teaching in inner city schools.
That's right.
That's when you started waking up and that's what sort of forced you to or force
you or led you to write the blog.
Yeah.
What were some of the ideas that you were seeing specifically that you realize,
wow,
this is not working in these schools?
Yeah.
So,
so one of the big things that I used to think before going into teaching and
everyone used to just accept was that,
uh,
black kids failed at school because white teachers are racist.
The system is racist,
the white teachers are racist.
And that's why black kids are failing.
Teachers go into teaching for racist purposes.
Not Anything.
This is what's so crazy,
I was thinking,
but I've met hundreds,
thousands of teachers,
not one of them has ever said to me,
I'm a racist and I want to stop black kids from promise,
like feeding.
In fact,
they are killing themselves,
you know,
working all hours,
giving everything that they can do the job.
Um,
and I started to question the kinds of things that the,
that the,
that the normal,
the normal way of seeing things was,
uh,
what I was being told.
Um,
and it wasn't just that,
you know,
in which we might get into later about teaching methods and about,
um,
uh,
discipline and so on.
The kinds of things are important and the whole second half is going to be on
your solution.
Right.
Okay.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
So,
yeah,
I started to question all of that.
And,
um,
I went,
there was this a black achievement,
uh,
kind of conference that used to happen once a year,
which was about improving black achievement and how,
what do we do raising black achievement?
And,
uh,
there was,
labor.
Uh,
so that's our left,
uh,
political policy.
Um,
black,
a woman MP.
So one of our politicians who used to run this thing.
And I went along and I took,
uh,
one of the white teachers who I worked with and he was older than me.
He's retired now and he'd been doing this for 25 years and I've given everything
to the job.
And I took him along and these people were standing up on stage,
essentially saying that white teachers were racist.
And I was so embarrassed.
I was so humiliated that I taken this man giving up his Saturday to go and sit
and be told that he's a racist when he had given everything to these black boys.
So we worked in this boy's school and it was mainly black boys in this school.
And um,
and I was just,
I was mortified.
Um,
so gradually I started to change my mind on these sorts of things and then I
started to see that they're with,
it had to do with our expectations of kids.
It had to do with our,
um,
our expectations of parents.
It had to do with the kinds of values that,
that we were giving them.
So if we were saying to them,
poor you,
you're a victim,
life is so difficult.
You're black,
you'll never be able to get anywhere.
Then it's quite hard for the black inner city boy go,
oh,
well,
you know,
actually it's about working hard.
It's about,
we always say at school,
even when it's difficult,
um,
especially when it's difficult,
you do what's right.
Right.
And as opposed to saying that it's difficult,
I can't do it right.
Except before Mckayla,
that that business of even when it's difficult,
especially when it's difficult,
that,
that value,
that business of believing in hard work,
I didn't see it so much.
Um,
and,
and we would give kids excuses.
We would give kids excuses to fail and,
um,
I wouldn't do it in my classroom.
And,
uh,
the kids behave for me and the kids learned with me.
And of course I'm not the only teacher was doing that.
There are teachers all over the place in their own classrooms.
We're doing that.
Uh,
what I,
what I wanted to do,
the administration,
they can you,
cause it sounds like,
you know,
Whoa,
we've got you.
And obviously as you said,
you weren't the only one,
but we've got people pushing against the very cause that's the fabric of what
these schools eventually become,
that it's not,
it's not on them.
It's on the system that is ruined because people before they've even begun yet.
Yeah,
they're poor.
I mean,
I don't suppose people realize what I was saying.
You know,
I mean I'm,
you're talking to kids privately,
you do your own thing.
And if the kids are behaving for you and you're getting good results and then,
then the principal loves you,
you know,
uh,
it just works and people don't know why.
Um,
and I'm not even sure I realized why,
you know,
you just,
you,
you build up an experience over years and you know what works for the kids and
how you get them on board and how you show them that you're in charge and,
and then you teach them properly and they love you for it.
Um,
yeah.
And realize that your political evolution was happening at the exact same time
because he was sort of very personal in the classroom,
but then that you were evolving.
Yeah.
It would have been in another sense,
uh,
cause I can be,
that's how it is for a lot of people.
When people come up to me on the street or email me,
they're saying,
you know,
something's happening at work on dealing with this and now it's starting to make
me think differently about politics.
Or I used to always vote Democrat,
but you know,
something happened in my family.
We got
in a conversation and now I'm starting to think something else is a little bit
different.
Well that was the blog.
Yeah.
So it was the conservatives on my blog that I was realizing,
I'm agreeing with you and I'm not agreeing with the left wingers on the blog.
Uh,
and it was then that I just thought,
well maybe I am just a conservative.
So I,
um,
I accepted it and then in,
you know,
accepted the idea of being conservative.
And then in 2010,
I voted conservative,
which was a major deal for me.
Um,
and it was funny cause you know,
after I did that,
I remember,
um,
this is after I ended up in the press and so on.
I was speaking to a friend of mine and I said to her,
and she's Indian.
And I said to her,
you know,
it will obviously you've seen in the press and everything and how I voted
conservative.
And she said,
well,
you know,
I have something to tell you Katherine.
I voted conservative too.
And that's the thing.
People are doing this and the canned admit to it,
it's so crazy.
So I voted conservative in May,
2010 and then in October,
2010 I was invited to go to the Conservative Party conference to,
to give,
uh,
a speech.
And that's like a convention.
You guys have conventions here.
And,
um,
I was a teacher.
I never really took much notice of political things.
I mean,
I,
I didn't,
I was a bit naive and a bit stupid to be honest.
And,
um,
anyway,
I went along and I gave this speech,
which,
uh,
the audience really liked and,
um,
and then I ended up all over the press.
This is the speech really,
that changed everything that changed my life.
Yeah.
Uh,
for the worst at the time.
I mean,
I think now I can look back and say it was for the better in many ways,
or at least,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
every cloud has a silver lining and my silver lining has been,
has been a good one,
uh,
because I've made it into a silver lining,
but I could have been,
uh,
destroyed by it quite easily.
I mean,
in the end,
I ended up without a job.
I was told,
uh,
that I would never get a job in state education ever again.
Lay out some of the things that you talked about in the speech.
Right?
So
I talked about black kids failing and that I talked about,
um,
I talked about that's not expecting enough of kids and how we are constantly
making excuses for them and how we label them with things like anger management
or I,
you know,
uh,
dyslexia or,
or all these kinds of labels that we give the kids.
Oh,
he can't possibly be behave.
He's,
he's got issues.
That's what we always say they have,
they have particular needs and,
uh,
we have to meet their needs,
um,
as opposed to just expecting them to behave.
Um,
everybody has different needs.
Nobody,
we can't expect anything of them.
And that's just the norm.
It's the norm.
So I,
I talked about all of this.
I talked about competition and how it was needed in schools that kids need to
feel as if they're competing against somebody else and so on.
They need to feel like they're being inspired to work hard as opposed to being
indulged.
Um,
and constantly let off the hook because while it's not your fault,
your parents are divorced,
it's not your fault cause you live on an estate and you're black and you're mom
is a single mom and you can't possibly do your homework.
I mean,
I don't understand this,
you know,
like,
and,
and that was because over the years,
you know,
I visited,
I'd worked for a summer one since South Africa.
I'd been to see schools in China and Brazil and India and all of these countries
where the kids were for poor and yet they were walking five miles getting to
school and working really hard.
So why was it that those kids could do it?
And apparently our kids couldn't do it,
you know?
So that was why I questioned it.
And I said all of this stuff at the conference and the Conservatives liked what
I said.
Yeah.
Cause nobody ever says this sort of thing.
And then as I say,
it was out of a job and then I thought,
what do I do?
How does that happen?
So you give this speech,
you're fired the next day.
I mean,
no,
I resigned in the end,
but it was just untenable.
Like,
yeah,
the press,
I was,
I was everywhere.
It was like one of those Hollywood films.
I couldn't go outside my door because there were press waiting outside to talk
to me.
Yeah.
Like I said,
I'm still responsibilities a thing.
Go get her.
This is what's so crazy.
All I said was ultimately I was saying that the education system was broken and
people wouldn't have that on.
The thing is I do feel it's like the emperor's new clothes,
which is that,
um,
everybody knows that there's a problem with the education system,
but nobody's willing to say it.
Uh,
and I,
I got hundreds,
if not thousands of emails from teachers all over the country saying,
thank God someone said something.
Thank you for saying something.
I won't tell you my name.
Yeah.
I can't tell you my name because I'll lose my job because they're all terrified.
Right.
So,
so yeah.
So I,
um,
I then thought about the private sector for a bit,
but then I thought,
I love working with disadvantaged kids.
I love working in the inner city.
This is what I do.
This is what I know.
I knocked,
I'm not giving up.
So we had just,
you've had charter schools in America for a long time.
We,
it was only in 2010 that free schools,
which are charter schools started in,
you know,
there was the possibility of setting one up.
So I decided to set up my own school and I got a group of people together and
then we started trying to set it up.
Now this was not easy because I had a lot of people who hated me.
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean I still have a lot of people pay me.
I said,
I do think the number is probably reduced.
Um,
or at least they've just left me alone.
Actually.
I don't know if the numbers reduced.
I think they just leave me alone.
I think at some point they see that you keep going,
that's it and keep becoming successful.
And then they'll always find someone new to feed on and to scare.
But it's like they,
you know what I mean?
Like at some point they're like,
wow,
yeah,
we haven't got her yet.
And then they run out.
They're not into hard work really.
So they kind of were like,
all right,
let's move onto an easier target.
Yeah.
And it is,
I am a more,
um,
it's harder now because,
because I have the school and it's really hard,
although they do try,
you know,
when we were trying to set up the school,
I wasn't used to say,
gosh,
it's like we're like making nuclear bombs.
I mean,
all we're doing is setting up a school.
we would,
um,
we would have parents evenings.
So first of all,
I'd be out on the street handing out flyers,
uh,
running into hairdressers and saying,
does anybody have any children who might want to go to the secondary school?
And you know,
women would be coming out of their hair dryers saying,
okay,
I'll have one,
I'll have one going into churches and mosques and temples and all sorts.
And then we would have a parent's evening once we had it in the pub.
And all these parents who are arriving,
our detractors are outside picketing that got like posters saying Tory teacher.
Um,
all sorts of insults is screaming obscenities at me,
calling me names and we have to hire a bouncer cause we were so worried about
the possible violence.
Um,
and then when I was talking to the parent,
these two parents finding out about a school,
that's it.
And they're all poor parents from the inner city,
right?
So you've got all these black mom's black single mom's sitting there trying to
find out about this new school and all these white middle class people.
And when we say middle class,
we mean people with money.
You guys use it as a working you.
Okay.
When we say middle class,
you,
you guys say middle class,
we mean working class.
When I say middle class I mean well off people.
So these white,
you know,
well educated,
well off,
people are,
have infiltrated on,
are sitting amongst all of these inner city people,
uh,
who are wanting to find out about the school.
And when I'm talking they're standing up and shouting abuse deliberately cause
they're trying to disrupt kind of like when you do stuff and like the shaking
pennies and yeah.
Yeah.
We'll do,
we're going to talk about that.
Cause I know you had a little criticism of the way I dealt with one of the
issues there related to education.
But we'll get to that.
But yeah.
So but,
but let's just focus on that for a second.
What do you think it is about the intentions of those people?
I try not to judge people's intentions.
I try to judge their actions.
But bees,
these working class and,
and I know you're not into identity politics,
but they happen to be white,
which you're illustrating here that they're the ones that are attacking the
black mothers that are trying to take care of their kids.
What is it that these people,
what do you think they really think?
Why do you think they really are so invested in keeping everything the way it
was?
They'll die.
They'll say that they're for helping these people all the time.
Then they'll look at a system that does not help these people.
Then someone comes in and says,
I'm going to help these people.
Yeah.
There's a track record of doing it.
And they hate you and them.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they do.
Um,
and so just so I'm clear,
these are white well off people,
right?
These are people who are,
who have everything.
Some of them have been privately educated.
Right.
I think it's because they believe in making people equal.
But the state should make people equal as opposed to giving people equality of
opportunity.
Because I'm all about giving people equality of opportunity.
I want to make it so that schools are so good,
but everybody has an equal chance of making something of themselves and changing
their stars.
Right.
That's what I want to do.
Yeah.
They don't like that.
They want these people to continue being not,
not being successful.
And then they as kind of these,
these white knights in shining armor can come down and the state can provide you
with money and,
and uh,
and a free apartment and,
and all sorts of things.
And then they can sit at parties and feel very good about themselves because,
well,
you know,
I vote on the left and I'm a very good person.
Um,
well this is it.
So they're not interested in whether or not it works.
Right.
They're interested in feeling good about themselves and their,
they genuinely believe that the state is going to make things better for these
people and free schools,
charter schools,
while they are state schools,
um,
they break up the education system,
right?
So the unions aren't as powerful anymore and they very much believe in the power
of the unions.
Um,
and they want them to have their collective bargaining.
And if too many schools break out of the system and break up the system,
then it,
it devalues that power of the unions.
Um,
so I think that they convinced themselves that what they're doing is right.
Even though there are all these poor moms wanting to find out about another
option for their child,
and they're desperate.
I mean,
when I say desperate,
I've had mothers crying in front of me crying saying,
I don't want my child to get knifed.
I don't want,
I want my child to have a decent education so that maybe he'll have a chance to
get to university.
I just want him to be safe.
Right.
And,
and then people are,
and then what they'll do is they'll deny that,
that,
that that's the case.
That there are schools where children aren't safe.
They'll deny,
they just,
they just lie there just boldface the highlights about,
about the system.
So what other kind of pushback did you get as you were creating the school?
Like what,
what is it like to you?
Okay,
you,
you fill out some paperwork.
I assume that now you try it,
you talk to some people and maybe you talked to some teachers than likeminded
people that say and things,
but what's that light to go?
I've got to find a building.
I got to find funding.
The whole that's right.
So it's a total nightmare.
Total nightmare.
I mean,
really,
whenever any group comes to me and says we want to set up a school,
I always say,
okay,
well dig deep,
right?
Cause you're going to have to get every bit of energy.
You've got to be able to push through on this.
I mean,
it took us three years,
um,
and it took us three years to find a building.
There was so many people against us.
Um,
and as you were saying earlier,
I just kept going and I mean,
I kind of had to keep going because otherwise I wasn't going to be able to do
the job that I love.
So a hat too.
And eventually we found this building.
I mean,
so first you apply,
you have to go for interviews,
you know,
the panel interviews and Blah Blah,
and then you'd get approved and then you're looking for a building and oh,
it's just a little nightmare.
But,
um,
eventually we got this building,
uh,
which,
you know,
isn't the greatest building.
And when I say it's not great,
you know,
there's no grass there,
no trees,
there's no car park for the staff.
There's just the old car park,
which is used as a playground for the kids,
which is tiny.
You know,
it isn't ideal,
but I always say it's the people inside the building that matter.
And we've made a real go of it.
And,
um,
and,
you know,
it's,
it's great.
It's,
it's,
and what is great,
but what he really is great.
And this is where,
you know,
I,
I'm really,
you know,
I feel really optimistic is that we have five,
10 teachers from all over the world that come and visit the school every single
day,
mainly from the UK.
But we get Americans,
Canadians,
Australians,
New Zealanders.
I mean,
and they come because they've heard about us through social media and they want
to see what we do.
And then we get loads of letters from teachers,
from principals who say,
are taking these ideas.
And I put them in my school and it's really helped.
And,
and it's made things better for our kids.
So I feel like we're not just having impact in our school,
on our kids,
but on,
on kids all over the world,
you know?
Yeah.